find the probability of rolling doubles
on two six-sided dice numbered from one
to six numbered from one to six so let's
just think about it let's think about
all of the outcomes all of the possible
outcomes and then what fraction of those
outcomes represent us getting doubles we
want to get we want to roll doubles so
let's make a little table here that'll
give us all of our outcomes you have six
outcomes on the first dice or the first
die i should say so 1
two
one two three
four
five six so let's call this the first
die
first
and then the second die there are six
outcomes
so one
two
three
four
five six this is the second die
second die so all of the different
possible outcomes are going to be some
you're going to get an outcome for so
you could get a 3 over here and then
when you get a 3 on the second die you
might have gotten a 1 2 3 4 5 or 6 on
the first die or you might have gotten a
5 on the first die and then you could
get a 1 2 3 4 5 or 6 on the second die
so if i draw a grid here
if i were to draw a grid here let me do
my best to draw a quick grid
just draw it really fast so let me just
draw this grid right here
each cell of this grid
each box in this grid would represent an
outcome
all of the possible outcomes
let me finish drawing it
so there you go and so just to get an
understand of understanding what i mean
but it represents an outcome
this cell right here this cell right
here would represent getting a 4 on your
first diet and a 2 on your second diet
that's the outcome it represents it's
one of the potential outcomes how many
total outcomes are there well you could
look at the area of this right here the
area of this is going to be 6 times 6
you have 36 possible outcomes so 36
possible
36 possible outcomes
and it makes sense you have you can
think about the first die there's one
there's six outcomes and then for each
of those six outcomes you have six
possible outcomes for the second die so
six times six or you could think of in
this grid the air it has exactly 36
cells in it now what are the outcomes
that satisfy our conditions that that
entail us getting doubles what are the
outcomes there well we're gonna get we
could get a one if we get a one on the
first die we have to get a one on the
second die if we get a two on the first
die we have to get a two on the second
die we get a three on the first die we
have to get a three on the second die i
think you see where this is going four
and four
five and five
and then six and six so how many of
these outcomes
involve us getting double well it's one
two three four five
six outcomes
there are six
six
outcomes
with
doubles
so someone asks you what's the
probability what is the probability of
getting
doubles probability of getting doubles
when you rolled two six-sided dice
numbered from one to six it's going to
be equal to the number of outcomes that
give us doubles so it's going to be
equal to 6 over the number of the total
number of possible outcomes
over 36
and 6 over 36 is 1 6.
now i went made sure that you kind of
understood that look these are all the
possible outcomes and then these six of
them satisfy so 6 of the 36 so there's a
1 6 probability of rolling doubles but
another way you could have thought about
it is you know what let's just roll the
first die it's going to have some number
on it right the first tie is going to
have some number on it now in order for
me to have doubles the second die has to
have that same exact number on it right
so i don't care what the first i get it
could be a three it could be a four it
could be a five i don't know what that
is but after that i've rolled that first
die in order to get doubles what the
second die roll is you know they might
be almost simultaneous but the second
die
rolls matters and so whatever number i
have there is a on the first die there's
a one sixth chance that the second die
is going to have that same that same
number on it so that's another way of
reasoning that you have a one sixth
chance first die does anything it wants
but there's only one in sixth chance
that the second die is going to have the
same thing as the first die either way
you get to the same 1 6 answer